hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
hi I'm Joan I'm free will change that
introduction one day I don't like
signature catchphrases let me get
straight to the point here we are gonna
watch today from the channel Vince
Jeremy Marvel Tony Stark the fallen a
character tribute video I'm assuming top
reward to your patron video request
Lance door can't ignore this requests
for more am i right yes I am I am Sam
Gmail spam a famous man once said we
create our own demons who said that what
does that even mean
doesn't matter I said it cuz he said so
now he was famous and they're basically
getting set by two well-known guys I
don't I'm gonna start again let's track
this from the beginning
truth is seems like a thousand years ago
now he's dr. Dolittle I bought my bear
to that cave became Iron Man realized
I'd left you I don't have
analysts said no more surprises but I
was really hoping to call off one last
one
now shoot me laughing some US service
fairies crazy I just finally know
[Music]
I know in my heart that it's right
I have to know I'm stunt man again and I
have to protect the one thing I can't
let you in my suit stir they're part of
me just action baby
no I can't have everything sort of seems
like he can not understand
I can put a penny right now that's not
[Music]
you it's not even about us it's about
legacy it's about what we choose to be
behind it's not about how much we lost
it's about how much we have left worthy
of interest
[Music]
I think
are we guys playing together
we'll lose dam and we'll do that
together true
yes otherwise the what we needed was a
Sunnah armor around the world remember
that whether it impacted our precious I
said we these you said desert cap with
the lost
[Music]
truth
[Music]
we have to take we did
with your own failure hope there were
many and they will
[Music]
who's next up maybe while he comes and
maybe it's too much for us but it's all
on you
we can protect the Earth you can be damn
well sure we'll avenge for a time
teachers to see how it possible
and then
[Music]
what did that bring you
[Music]
today
my originating a half-life
[Music]
as long as they're those boys
we're able to accept work in
[Music]
we will change the world
what is and always my greatest screech
is you
[Music]
and so as Christmas morning began my
journey agreed it said
start something sure
[Music]
so you say
[Music]
then communist state
[Music]
we map this video out
yeah
maybe when it comes to babies in my
presence
[Music]
Partha journeys the end Vince
one guy just Vinnie well Vince Vince my
friend Vince this is a supremely edited
and wonderfully wonderfully edited right
down to the closing moment for when he
says I am Iron Man also added extra like
Rumble echoing effect when every time he
spoke a word there but then cutting back
and forth to the first time he donned
the full Iron Man suit in Iron Man 1 and
then going to the moment where he snaps
to the end of his journey I thought was
beautifully told and picking the right
amount of dialogue and monologues to use
to overlap all the footage was brilliant
you know or very early on they talked
about leaving behind a legacy or is that
the stark Expo and it just made me go
about me well Robert Downey jr. himself
has left behind a legacy it's crazy how
much this journey of Ironman kind of
shadows Robert Downey jr. journey as
well it's like different for Hugh
Jackman and Wolverine
like these are the two characters you go
to for the ones who have played the
compactors the longest most iconic most
like strongly associated with that's the
actor I associated with that character I
Hugh Jackman and Wolverine is like two
totally different people or is like RDJ
and Tony Stark you view them similarly
you know I mean Tony Stark Robert Downey
jr. basically there's like do you buddy
this kind of reminded me of the Captain
American when we watched although more
down the dramatic side of things because
they you know these more stark haha sure
yeah for Tony yeah because I think you
associate him with a certain amount of
you know humor in a certain amount of
attitude and I like that this really
highlighted across all the different
films really the rise to responsibility
and taking up this mantle that maybe he
didn't ask for and maybe he wasn't
prepared for when he first started out
both in this series and in the story and
then yeah watching just the way this
character has grown and straightened up
into a very upstanding truly heroic
person it was nicely encapsulated
through here and I like that you really
kind of evenly represented all the
different movies I was honestly a little
distracted half the time going how is
this on YouTube with all this end game
footage because there are moments that
I'm sure Marvel didn't just put
they're to be on the internet so by that
I'm used to YouTube just doing that all
the time you know that theme of legacy
is so present and destiny as well you
know you use Howard Starks quote about
how you were my greatest creation from
Iron Man to and I thought it was
important to include the end game
footage not just because of the fact
that you know he sacrifices himself in
there but also pass on a legacy to
pepper and Morgan by the end of that
journey so it's beautiful I never really
quite beauty as something of Destiny but
that's something that this highlighted
for me especially because I think about
how joss whedon included Thanos in
Avengers Assemble is just a fun thing
and then they went with it but somehow
they MC you and all the you know Emma
fighting everyone involved managed to
make that whole Thanos arc as well so I
thought was cool to include a lot of the
Thanos side here sort of showing this
equal opposition in a way for Tony Stark
someone who's a sort of reflection of
him for some of this journey and
enhancing the whole destiny element as
well mmm
yeah definitely it kind of feels like at
least as a fictional character what his
gift was given to the world for you know
so yeah it was that that this was really
nice and it made my heart quiver a
little bit he's thinking back across the
journey yeah him and his bug eyes Tony
Tony bug eyes stark well thanks Lance
store for requesting this guy's you
cannot subscribe to a Vince's channel
bids Jeremy two first names that's cool
yeah brother of Ron Jeremy just
subscribe today you guys subscribed the
real rejects click that notification
bell hit that like button Lance my buddy
this guy's been working his ass off
lately he's a firefighter I don't know
how you take on extra shifts as a
firefighter do you have friends set
fires in Canada start fires and you just
get the call do you get a pay grade
raise or something like that I don't
know how it works but basically he is
taking a European vacation on 4th of
July that's anti-american if you're
gonna take a vacation on 4th of July you
come to America Canadian Texas he said
we are hitting an order Rome Venice
Florence
Godiva chocolate London and Paris all in
a span of 16 days this is the biggest
trip he's ever been on but really needs
to do it well if there's anything I've
learned about traveling the shorter of a
time you have to travel the less
stressful that is it's usually you're
just very on top of it especially a kid
it's gonna be smooth sailing you really
gonna be able to slow down and absorb
everything you're taking in if anything
you should cut this trip down to like
ten days and and I'd always been better
yeah and I'd like three or four more
destinations you know because Europe is
not a very Hugh I'm een like it's a lot
of land but there's a lot of countries
tightly packed into it so I feel like
you're kind of under selling the
potential of all the places yeah see
this is it's overrated the places you're
going to yeah man who needs Godiva
chocolate you should have gone to
America
we got Wisconsin we got Utah Montana we
have Arizona Florida New Mexico
Massachusetts North Dakota Maine all
these great very touristy spots that you
should have checked out instead of
Geneva these anti-american mother effers
[Laughter]
America and Canada yep America's hat
good luck
hi